welcome I thanks for joining us I'm
Jennifer Dunn
I'm a professor at the Santa Fe
Institute and before I introduce mark
I'd like to wish Murray gell-mann a very
happy birthday I think he turned sitting
here in the front row I think he turned
18 or something today I forget exactly
what some combination of those numbers
anyway it's my pleasure to introduce
Mark Newman for his second of three
Santa Fe Institute Alam lectures on our
small world how networks of people and
information shape our world mark is the
Paul Dirac collegiate professor of
physics and a member of the Center for
the Study of complex systems at the
University of Michigan and he is one of
the world's foremost experts and
authorities on networks his work on the
fundamentals of network theory and it's
applications began to take shape during
his postdoctoral fellowship at the Santa
Fe Institute in 1996 to 1998 and
continued through his appointment as
professor there where he now also serves
as on the science board so last night
for those of you who are here mark gave
an excellent and stimulating
introduction to our connected world he
clearly explained what networks are and
gave very interesting examples of
technological information biological and
social networks he also described how
such data is painstakingly compiled and
put together and as someone who works at
the intersection of ecology and networks
on food webs I know how difficult it can
be to collect and compile really good
detailed Network data tonight we will
hear Marc talk about what networks can
tell us about the word world in other
words what we can do with all the
network data that he presented last
night mark has made many fundamental
contributions to our understanding of
how networks are structured and he will
open a window on some of those insights
during his talk tonight while most of
Mark's scores of papers that deal with
basa a deal with basic theory and
analysis related to the structure of
networks last night he mentioned some of
his interesting applications of network
research for example
little networks of the UL US House of
Representatives and sexual networks on
which epidemics akin spread and you'll
hear more about epidemics tomorrow night
but before he comes on I wanted to
mention one other paper which many
Americans would find of interest
especially starting at this time of the
year the title of that paper is a
network-based ranking system for
American college football so the next
time you glimpse a football game on TV
you can think back to its unlikely
connections to the set of Santa Fe
Institute alum lectures on networks by
Mark Newman thank you very much Jennifer
for that very nice introduction so as
she mentioned this is the second of
these three lamb lectures and the topic
is networks I was going to start by
giving a brief summary of the things
that I talked about last night but
Jennifer already did that very well for
me but just in case you didn't make it
last night what we talked about is sort
of what is a network
answer is it's a bunch of dots connected
together by lines the jargon is we call
the dots nodes and we call the lines
edges I know that's kind of jargony but
it comes up all the time everybody does
it so get used to it why are we
interested in it works because they can
represent all sorts of things in the
real world
for instance they can represent
technological networks like the internet
information networks like the world wide
web a network of webpages connected
together by hyperlinks biological
networks such as food webs for Jennifer
studies and social networks which and
networks with people for example who's
friends with whom or who knows whom I
described some examples of these
networks how we measure things about
them and some of the things that we
found out by looking and their works and
now tonight I want to say something
about what can we do with all this stuff
that we've learnt about all these
different networks in the world I want
to give you some examples of interesting
things that we've discovered by taking
the networks that we've measured and
looking at them more carefully so
here's one example of a simple thing
that we can do once we know about
networks suppose that you have some
network you take a look at a network
like this is actually a social network
and you can clearly see that not
everybody in this network is equal there
are some people who are in the thick of
things here in the middle of the network
and then there are other people who are
sort of more peripheral around the edges
of the network so then you might look at
this and ask it you ask yourself well
what can I say about how central or
important different people are in this
network some people are going to be sort
of well-connected in the middle of the
network and some people are going to be
less well-connected people so this leads
us to an idea that network analysis
refer to as centrality centrality is
this idea of which is the most important
note in network who is the most
important person in a social network or
in the web network who is what's the
most important webpage well of course
the answers to these questions depends
strongly on what you mean by important
there are various different ways that a
person could be important in a social
network but to give you one example
suppose I could I could be thinking of
distances in a network and who's close
to whom within the network so if I'm
connected to somebody else in a network
there's a direct connection from me to
you then you're one step away from me in
the network I know you if that if you
have some friends that I don't know then
those people are two steps away from me
in their network I have to go one step
from me to you and then one step from
you to your friends so those people are
still quite close to me to me I could
get in contact with them if I had to but
they are further away from me than you
are so there's this concept of distance
in a network and one way I could think
of of being well connected in a network
is I was some I'm looking for somebody
who is not very far from everybody else
in the network so this leads us to
consider this idea of distances in a
network so let's take a little moment to
consider this idea of distances in
network this is something that people
have studying networks for a long time
in fact one of the most famous
experiments done on social networks was
an experiment done by Stanley Milgram in
the 1960s which is often referred to as
the small world experiment and possibly
you've heard of this experiment so
that's a picture of Stanley Milgram over
there he was at the time a professor at
Harvard University and even if you
haven't heard of this experiment you
might have heard of Stanley Milgram for
another reason
he did another set of experiments now
considered rather notorious about
obedience in which he got experimental
subjects to press a button which
allegedly gave an electric shock to
another person that they could see
through a glass window in another room
it was all faked nobody actually got an
electric shock was just an actor
pretending but the person who's pressing
the button didn't know that and what
they discovered in this experiment is
that if an authority figure tells you
you should press this button in this
case a Harvard University professor and
a lot of people will do it even though
they know that they shouldn't do this I
mean it's clearly a bad thing to do
right you shouldn't press the button and
give the person the electric shock but a
lot of people it turns out will so this
series of experiments taught us some
rather disturbing things about people's
response to authority figures it also
ended up getting Stanley Milgram fired
from Harvard University because it is
clearly a deeply unethical experiments I
mean obviously this is a bad thing to do
I mean the poor people who participated
in this experiment apparently some of
them were in therapy for years
afterwards so so so that's probably the
most famous thing he did but before he
did that experiment he did this other
experiment which is really quite clever
so what he did in this experiment
arrested in these pass-through net ways
how close are people twelve people how
many handshakes are you away from
another person in a network so he did a
clever experiment to determine this he
sent letters to a bunch of people and he
asked those people to get the letters to
a target person who was a friend of his
who was a stockbroker who lived in
Boston the majority of the people were
chosen from the City of Omaha Nebraska
some of them were also people in Boston
and so he sent them this letter and he
said well you have to get this letter to
this target person but the catch is you
can't just send it straight to the
target person
you can only give it to somebody that
you know on a first-name basis so you
probably don't know stockbroker in
Boston on a first name basis but so what
you have to do is you have to think do I
know somebody who's closer than me to
this target person and I could pass it
to them and then maybe they can pass it
along and get it to the target person so
that could mean closer in you know a
real Geographic sense like maybe you
know somebody lives in Boston or
somebody lives in Massachusetts or it
could mean closer in some social sense
like you might know somebody else who
works in the financial industry or
something like that anyway you get to
choose whatever you do and you then you
pass the letter along to and then the
next person repeats the exercise and
decides to pass it along and so the
letter hops through a succession of
acquaintances in this way but the letter
is basically surfing across the social
network from acquaintances to
acquaintances in the hope is that
eventually it will reach the target
person this spot broker in Boston it
turned out in fact that most of the
letters did not get there perhaps on all
a big surprise you know people get this
thing in the mail and they say what is
this and they chuck it in the trash but
a small number of them 64 letters about
29% did arrive at the target person and
so the famous result which you may have
heard of is that took on average about
six steps for those letters to get from
you no random person in Omaha Nebraska
to a stockbroker in Boston this is the
origin of this famous expression the six
degrees of separation this idea so I'm
sort of almost mythical now that you are
six handshakes away from everyone else
in the world so you can play this with
yourself here's an example here's me and
I'm going to connect me to the President
of the United States turns out to be not
that difficult to do I went to college
with a woman called Karen ruff whose
father was Chuck ruff there he is he is
a lawyer well he was he's dead now but
he was a lawyer working in Washington DC
and he was one of the defense lawyers
for Bill Clinton in his impeachment
trial and Bill Clinton knows Barak Obama
so there you go three steps one two
three and you've got from me to the
president of United States terrific okay
but now here's the catch you all know me
so that
you're four steps away from the
president of United States because you
know me and then it's three steps you
guys the president United States see
this is how it works yeah this is why
it's such a small world to put this in
slightly more mathematical terms here's
how it goes
suppose every person knows a hundred
people that means the number of people
one step away from you people one degree
of separation away from you is a hundred
just all the people you know all of them
know a hundred people so the number of
people two steps away from you is a
hundred times 100 which is ten thousand
three steps away 100 times 100 times 100
which is a million then you've got a
hundred million then you've got ten
million but that's actually more than
the total number of people in the world
there are only seven billion people in
the world so we've got all of them on we
only had to go five steps okay so it was
five not six but this is the basic idea
that that as you go out from your
starting point
it grows incredibly fast this is
actually what we call exponential growth
it's going up by a factor each time it
grows so fast that it doesn't take that
many steps before you've got to
everybody in the world this is sort of
the basic mathematical origin of the
small world effect so as I say this is
this is a result that has become a part
of the folklore now pretty much
everybody's heard of this thing for
instance there's this popular parlor
game the six degrees of Kevin Bacon
maybe you've heard of this game it's a
game where you try and connect movie
actors to Kevin Bacon in some small
number of steps and what's the
connection between movie actors it's
who's been in a movie with who else so
for instance Clint Eastwood was in The
Bridges of Madison County with Meryl
Streep and Meryl Streep was in a river
wild with Kevin Bacon they're two steps
and I've got from Clint Eastwood's here
in Baker and it turns out you can do
that with almost any actor it's not
because Kevin Bacon special of course
you could do this it doesn't matter who
you're aiming for you can do this with
salting with almost any actor and what
you're doing is you're surfing the
network of movie actors and the reason
it works is because the small world
effect is in play you've got this six
degrees of separation effect so you can
you can do you can you can play this
game people have a lot of fun with this
there's all sorts of things that you see
in in the papers you know Kevin Bacon
linked to al-qaeda only six steps there
well of course it's
only six steps that's the whole point
everybody's connected to everybody
else's six steps all right very good so
so this movie actor network is actually
kind of a fun example because it turns
out to be very well documented I mean
it's not you know this is not a serious
example but there's this thing called
the Internet Movie Database it's a
website that contains data about every
movie pretty much ever made including
who is in the movie so you can tell
who's been in movies with who else
because all the data is there so you can
go and actually assemble the entire
network of which actors have been in
which other movies here's a small
portion of it that I made a plot of just
just for this talk is 50 or so famous
actors and these are the connections
between them who's been in movies with
who else this is actually kind of an
interesting network I noticed a fried
made it that you notice there's this
sort of separate group over here on the
right which is like Waldo Hepburn Cary
Grant Clark Gable Spencer Tracy these
are all the old-timers and then this
group over here is sort of more modern
movie actors mostly and it seems like
for some reason Gregory Peck is the
pivotable pivotal connecting person who
connects the old-school black and white
Newman I have no idea why that is anyway
so you can act you can you can assemble
this entire network here and net so now
let's get back to the topic we were
talking about to begin with this idea of
sensuality who's the most important
person in the network so one way you
could do that is you say well if I can
calculate the distance through the
network from everybody to everybody else
then we could calculate the centrality
of a person as being the average
distance from you to everyone else in
the network so we're looking for people
who are never äj--
they don't have to go very far through
the network to get to anyone else so
this is one possible definition of being
an important person in the network you
know you don't have to go very far
through the network to get to anybody
else that you want to talk to so you're
a well-connected person well you can
calculate that kind of thing and I did
it for example for this movie acting
Network just cuz you haven't
the data so this is the thing we call
closeness sensualities divined is the
average distance to everyone else in the
network and it's good if it's small
because you want to be a short distance
away from everyone else so here are the
people with a smallest average distance
to other people in this movie actor
Network the person with the shortest
average distance the most central person
in the movie actor network is
Christopher Lee two people know who
Christopher Lee is no yeah it's slightly
obscure actually he's this guy he's a
b-movie actor who was in a lot of movie
bad horror movies where he played you
know versions of Dracula and stuff like
that
and more recently he's actually been in
a couple of better movies he also played
a wizard in the in the Lord of the Rings
and and a Jedi Knight person in one of
the new Star Wars movies anyway so he
was top of the list and probably the
reason for that is that he's just been
in an awful lot of movies so it probably
is actually pretty well connected the
other people are well connected it was a
bunch of famous people here Donald
Pleasence Charlton Heston Rod Steiger
John Gielgud notice that these are all
sort of actors from a slightly older
school of movies and that's probably
again just because they've had time
enough to accumulate a lot of credits
they just been a lot of movies so
they're well connected so this would be
one example of one way we could sort of
pinpoint important people in a social
network by taking the network and
analyzing it it's actually not a very
good way of doing it so it has some
disadvantages one is that it's hard to
calculate in order to calculate the
average distance from me to everyone
else in the network I need to calculate
the distance from me to everyone else in
the network and turns out that that's a
pretty hard thing to do I mean of course
we do this on a computer you understand
but even so a computer takes a long time
to do this calculation just because it's
a very complicated calculation another
disadvantage with it is kind of more
subtle it's nearly the same for everyone
look at these numbers Christopher Lee
two point four one three Donald
Pleasance two point four one six there's
only a tiny difference there a few
thousandths difference what that means
is if there was a small change in the
network you know a node appears here and
edge disappears there
then these numbers would probably change
a little bit not very much but they only
have to change a little bit and it could
upset the order maybe Donald Pleasance
would leap into the lead so you don't
want to measure where you're ranking of
who's most important depends on tiny
little changes in your network so for
that reason this is kind of an
unsatisfactory measure so so then the
next question is well what can we do
that's better well there are various
things we can do but let me give you one
simple example of something we could do
this is really a very simple idea
something called degree centrality the
degree of a node in a network is just
how many other nodes it's connected to
so if we're talking about a friendship
network it's how many friends you have
if we're talking about the world wide
web it's how many links there are to
your webpage so if you look at a network
like this one there's some nodes that
have very high degree meaning they have
a lot of connections and there are some
nodes here or something that have low
degree meaning they have few connections
so degree centrality is just that number
it's just let's say the most important
people in network are the people who
know the most people very simple idea
but it's a reasonable one as well I mean
you know people who know a lot of other
people could be influential that's
obviously an important thing and the
advantage of this is it's very easy to
calculate the the closeness centrality
that I just mentioned it requires you to
calculate the distance from you to
everybody else in the network which
means you need to know everybody else in
the network with this degree centrality
you don't in order to calculate
someone's degree centrality all you need
to know is how many people do they know
much simpler thing to calculate you
don't actually even need to know the
whole network to do that you can just
you know measure this one person that
said it turns out to be not entirely
trivial to work out how many people
somebody knows turns out if you just ask
someone how many people do you know most
people will get it completely wrong and
if you ask people you know can you write
down a list of everybody you know you
know most people could start writing
down some names but they run out of
steam after a while there's probably a
lot of people that they know that they
just can't happen to think of right at
this moment people are not good at doing
this exercise so instead
here's an alternative proposal that was
made by two sociologists Russ Bernard
bedico worth this turned out to work
quite well give people a list of common
surnames and ask them how many people do
you know with names on this list
that obviously doesn't tell you the
total number of people that they know
but it's a sample of the people you know
if you then know you know you gave them
this many names if you know how many
possible names there are total you know
in the whole country then you can scale
it up appropriately there's a fairly
simple mathematical equation which tells
you - how to scale up that number so you
can estimate the total number of people
that they know so I thought it might be
interesting we could try this exercise
with the audience here in the auditorium
tonight you don't have to if you don't
want to but it's kind of fun and
interesting what you get here is a list
of the 48 Communists surnames in the
United States what I like to do if
you're ok with this is - we'll just take
a few seconds and I'd like you to go
through this list and count how many
people you know with names on the list
so here are the rules if you know more
than one person with a name you count
all of them so if you know two people
called Adams
you count two if you know ten people
called Adams count 10 so you can't
everybody you know with a name on the
list and also we better be careful about
what we mean by no here so let's say no
means you know if you saw this person
walking down the street you'd recognize
them you'd say hello you greet them by
their first name they would know your
first name back okay so that's how well
you have to know someone for each
counters now I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
- we'll take a few seconds here and when
you count how many people you know with
names on the list so here we go
starting now
see if you feel still counting I think
I'm done give you a little more time
okay oh good no no a little more time
all right ten seconds more
okay very good
so most people finish now so now I'm
gonna take a poll how many people knew
between zero and ten people with names
on the list
okay quite a few people maybe thirty or
forty people how many people knew
between ten and twenty Oh Lots there
probably about eighty people in the
auditorium how many people knew between
twenty and thirty quite a few thirty and
forty okay it's getting thinner now
forty and fifty now so few people
holding out fifty and sixty sixty
seventy one two three four over seventy
how many people need more than 70 people
over 80 over nineteen Wow
over a hundred one person you over one
hundred just one person no two people
how many two hundred Wow and someone
back there as well you have 150 Wow okay
so very good so this is actually common
this is what you always find when you do
this experiment most of us know you know
a modest number of people 10 20 or
something with names on the list but you
usually find an any crowd this size that
there are a few people that know a lot
100 200 somebody knew 200 people with
names on the list and this is common
with a lot of networks if you look at
the degree at the number of connections
that nodes have that there are a few
nodes we call them the hubs in the
network that really have an enormous
number of connections and it turns out
that those hubs in the network can play
a disproportionate role in the behavior
in network even though there's only very
few of them it turns out they play a
really very important role in the
functioning of the network so this
measure of centrality this very simple
measure just count how many people you
know actually turns out to be pretty
good one it's pretty indicative of
of which nodes in the network are the
ones that are really going to affect the
system here's just one example of that
this is actually not a social network
this is the Internet this is the sort of
thing you see so this is just a bar
chart of degree in other words a number
of connections that nodes have the
network so this is how many nodes have
one connection this is how many nodes
have two three four five and you can see
that it's falling off but even when you
get out here there's still you know
fifteen or twenty there's still a small
number of nodes that have that many
connections this bit down here on the
right we call the long tail and that's
where these hubs reside there are only a
very few of them in the network they can
have this disproportionately large
effect on the behavior of the network so
just to sort of illustrate that here's
an actual picture of the Internet and
you can certainly see the hubs here as a
you know you see them as these big
bright centers of activity there's
clearly something important going on
here in the network those are the hubs
the ones that have a lot of connections
okay very good so this is a really
simple measure of importance in network
well that's actually pretty effective it
gets over both of the drawbacks that I
mentioned before for closeness
centrality the first one was that that
was hard to calculate well this is much
easier we just did it the second one was
that the the values were really close
together so that that the ranking might
easily change but with this degree it's
not true you know you have somebody with
a hundred connections and somebody one
hundred fifty and somebody with two
hundred that ranking is not going to
change you might change those numbers a
little bit but it's not gonna change who
comes in first new comes in second
they're well spaced values in other
words so he gets over that problem as
well
however it's not entirely perfect you
know basically what degree is doing is
it's giving you one point for everybody
you know right it's saying count up the
number of people and you get one point
for every what do you know but what do
you think about it that's kind of dumb
right because not everybody is equally
important and if you know the President
of the United States then that's way
better than knowing just some average
person right so a better way of doing
this slightly more sophisticated version
of the idea of degree is to give people
more points if they know people who
themselves
well connected so there's various ways
of doing that but but one way of doing
it is is a simple way you just give each
node a network score where instead of
getting one point for each person you
know you get however many points they
have so you just add up the scores of
the people that you know and that's your
score well if you think about this for a
moment you start to see that there are
some problems with this in order to work
out what your neighbors score is well
what do you how do you work out their
score will they add up the scores of the
people they know and those people they
aren't scores with people they know and
so forth so it seems like this is never
going to end there's going to be sort of
this infinite process of working out
what everybody score is just to work out
what your score is but it turns out
actually that's not true
there is a clever mathematical trick
called an eigenvector which allows you
to calculate all the scores just in one
step and you don't have to do this sort
of infinite regression thing so you can
do this this kind of score goes by
several names but one of its most famous
names is it's called PageRank PageRank
is actually a trade name that was given
to this idea by Google Corporation
Google Corporation use exactly this idea
this PageRank idea as a crucial central
part of their strategy for searching the
web when you do web searches on Google
they're using this kind of network idea
that your score is the sum of the scores
of the people next to you so how does
that work
so you're here's a picture of a portion
of the web one of the pictures that we
saw yesterday so the nodes in the web
represent web pages and the edges in the
web represent hyperlinks that link from
one page to another so Google's basic
idea is we're going to work out what in
which pages are important on the web by
looking at how many links they yet if
other people link to a page where they
put a hyperlink from their page to your
page they went to the trouble of doing
that presumably because they think your
page is good somehow they think it's
useful or interesting other people share
to look at it so lots and lots of people
have linked to your page that's a sign
that it's important but you can do a
most
fistic ate a version of that idea by
using this PageRank thing we don't just
say oh you get one point for each link
we now say you get some number of points
that depends on how important the people
who are who are linking to you and how
do we work out how important they are
well it's how many people link to them
and so forth back infinitely but you can
do this mathematical trick this
eigenvector and work out those scores
those are the PageRank scores so now
here's how Google works you type
something into Google for instance you
type in PageRank into Google and it goes
out and it finds a bunch of pages which
might have something to do with PageRank
at this stage they don't make any effort
to work out which are the pages that you
might find most interesting actually
they do kind of a deliberately bad job
and neces many pages as they can they
just look for anything that might have
the slightest thing to do with PageRank
that's why when you type in PageRank you
get 58 million eight hundred thousand
results right that's not because all of
those pages are really relevant you're
probably not interested in most of them
in facts but at this stage we're just
trying to find anything that you might
possibly find interesting but then
here's the clever bit you take that huge
number of pages and you print them out
in order putting the most important ones
first and how do you decide which is
most important you use PageRank so in
other words you calculate the PageRank
of those pages you find the one with the
highest PageRank and it comes first in
the list so when you type something into
Google very often the page that you're
looking for appears on this first page
of ten results that Google gives you for
the thing you typed in and that's
because Google is not doing a
particularly good job of finding pages
what's clever about Google is the order
in which it prints them out when it
finds them and the way it does that is
it uses the network it uses this
PageRank idea to work out which order to
print them out in and as you probably
know it's pretty effective it really
works and makes Google a lot of money ok
very good
so that's centrality that's one example
of the kinds of things that we can do
once we have a bunch of network data
there are many other examples I want to
tell you about a few of them here's one
thing that's kind of interesting another
very simple
if you look at a lot of networks here's
a this is a social network it's actually
a collaboration network of scientists
but this is true of many networks if you
look at them you find that there are a
lot of triangles in the network triangle
here bunch of triangles here some
triangles over here and here here common
thing in networks you see there are
triangles so let's think what does a
triangle mean in a social network a
triangle means one way of putting it
would be to say the friend of my friend
is also my friend
so I know someone they know someone and
I know that someone so the three of us
form a triangle or another way of saying
is I have two friends and they're both
friends with each other so the three of
us form a triangle either way so you've
got some node here here's me in the
middle I have a bunch of friends and at
least some of my friends know each other
this idea goes by the name of
transitivity it's a word we borrow from
mathematics transitivity is this idea
that the friend of my friend is also my
friend a and B and B and C means also a
and C so there's a friendship between a
and B there's a friendship between B and
C that means there's also a friendship
between a and C that's the idea we call
transitivity so it's kind of a fancy
word all it means is the friend of my
friend is also my friend
now imagine so one thing that can happen
in a network is that my friends are not
friends with each other so this is what
the alternative to this would be
something like this here's me I have a
bunch of friends but there's now no
connection between my friends so there's
gaps here where I would expect there to
be an edge in the social networks that
should they sometimes call those
structural holes it's a fancy name just
for just saying my friends don't know
each other if you talk to a sociologist
about their stuff they would say that
indicates that this person here in the
middle has more power and influence
because their friends are not connected
to each other that means that they act
as the broker between their two friends
those friends don't know each other
directly so information flow or contacts
between those people has to go through
them and that gives you more control
more influence more power that's a very
sort of typical sociologists peek
they're also always worrying about sort
of power
influence in networks the thing that I
want to talk about actually is is a much
simpler idea and it's this it's just the
idea that if you look for people who
have a mutual friends that's an
extremely good predictor that they will
become friends in the future that may
not sound like a big revelation it's
pretty obvious you know the friend of
your friend is somebody you're likely to
meet at parties or something like that
but it turns out to be to work really
well if you actually want to predict
who's going to be friends with whom in
the future this is an extremely
effective way of doing it here is an
example this graph comes from a paper
that I did a few years back and this is
actually for a scientific collaboration
network of the kind that I showed you
before so this is who's writing papers
with whom and I'm going to try and
predict who's going to write papers with
whom in the future so what this shows is
I take two people and look at how many
common neighbors they have in the
network in other words have they they
they haven't written a paper together
yet but they've both written papers with
some other third person or maybe they've
written papers with two other people or
three other people the person who has
written who had the two people who have
one common neighbor in this network
who've written a paper with the same
person it turns out are forty five times
more likely to collaborate in future
than two people who don't have a common
a but people who have two Combinator's
are over a hundred times more likely to
collaborate in future so this is a huge
effect this is a very effective way of
predicting something that's going to
happen and it's just using this very
simple network property which sort of
seems obvious in hindsight but even it's
obvious it can still be useful if this
is something you want to predict and you
have the network data then this is a
very effective way of predicting who's
going to be connected in the network in
future ok so this is a simple example of
sort of a structural network property
that you can use to predict things here
is another example of a network property
that's very useful for a lot of things
it's probably called homophony
here is a picture that you saw yesterday
this is one of
Moreno's hand-drawn social networks from
his book that came out in 1934 and as we
said yesterday this particular picture
represents a pattern of it so the notes
here represent elementary school
children playing in a playground and the
connections between them which kids are
playing with which other kids and you
immediately see when you look at this
figure there are two basic groups they
correspond to the boys and the girls the
boys are mostly playing with the other
boys and the girls are mostly playing
with the other girls this is the effect
that sociologists call him awfully that
just means you like people who are like
you and this is a very common affecting
networks that the connections tend to be
between people or more generally between
nodes that are similar in some way so
here most of the connections are either
between two boys or between two girls
they tend to play together in their
separate groups this is something that
turns up very often in a lot of
different networks I'll give you a bunch
of other examples here's a sort of
modern-day example of the same thing
this is a group of high school children
this is data taken from the ad Health
Project a big NIH project of on social
networks in high in u.s. high schools
and again in this high school you can
see saw the nodes of the kids in the
school and the edges are who's friends
with whom and you can see that it splits
up into two clear groups here but now
this is a high school and in the high
school the boys and the girls are often
friends but by the time they're this age
so these groups are not actually groups
of boys and girls these groups it turns
out are divided by race there's a group
of white kids here and a group of black
kids here and the white kids are mostly
playing with other white kids and the
black kids that will be playing with
other black kids so this is a similar
sort of effect it's still home awfully
people prefer to be acquainted with
other people that they perceive as being
similar to them in some way but it's a
monthly by different thing previously it
was gender in this case it's ethnicity
here's another example also taken from
the ad health and health data this is
who's friends with whom by age or
actually technically by grade but it's
roughly the same thing each dot on this
plot represents a friendship
between two kids and the age of one of
the kids well the grade of one of the
kids is long here in the greater the
other kid here and what you see is that
most of the dots sort of fall along this
dark band diagonally down the middle
that's telling you that people in ninth
grade are friends with other people in
ninth grade people in tenth grade
friends will help people in tenth grade
and so forth obviously not a big
surprise if you've ever been to high
school but but it's showing you that
people tend to be friends with other
people who are about the same age as
they are here's another example of a
similar thing this is who marries whom
this plot each dot shows one couple in a
study a large study of US couples called
the National Survey of family growth so
each dot represents one married couple
and the position of the dot tells you
the ages of the man and the woman at the
time they got married so age of the
husband along the horizontal axis age of
the wife along the vertical axis this
vertical axis only goes up to 40 that
doesn't mean that women don't get
married after age 40 it's just that in
this particular study they only
interviewed women up to age 40 so that's
why it stops there some of the women
they interviewed were married to men
over age 40 so that's why the male axis
goes on a little bit further but again
what you see in this plot is that most
of the dots lie along with sort of
diagonal band here indicating that
people are primarily getting married to
other people around the same age as they
are again probably not a big surprise
but it shows there is homophony in this
network
well technically actually who's married
to whom is not really a network because
you know in principle you're only
married to one person at a time
so wouldn't actually make a network but
I'm sort of thinking of this as a proxy
for who's friends with whom and
presumably you're friends with your
husband doing wife before you get
married to them so this is an indication
again that people tend to be friends
with acquainted with other people about
the same age here's another example this
is just I just wanted to give you one
non social network example this is a
world wide web example this is from a
study by my Michigan colleague Lada
Adamic
collaborate an athlete's glance and they
were studying web logs or blogs for
short blogs our personal websites on
which people post their opinions about
anything they want to but in this
particular study and a mac'n glance were
studying political web logs so these are
blogs on which people write stuff about
their political opinions and the blocks
that they studied divided into two broad
groups there were liberal ones in blue
here on the left and there was some
conservative ones in red here on the
right and then the edges again are
hyperlinks the link from one blog to
another and what they discovered is that
overwhelmingly the liberal blogs are
linking to other liberal blogs and the
conservative blogs linked to other
conservative blogs so again it's as if
conservatives like to be connected to
other conservatives and liberals lights
be connected to other liberals okay so
that's the basic idea of thermopylae how
can we use this to make predictions
about what's going on in the network
well here's a very simple example
consider again this network here of kids
in a high school if I were to take one
of the kids in one of these groups say a
kid over here one of the black kids and
look at their friends I would find
probably that their friends are
overwhelming black so if I just took a
simple majority vote just took some
random kid and looked at their friends
and took them a majority vote of whether
they're black or white that's a pretty
good predictor of where the kid themself
is black or white and turns out that
works very well if I just take a simple
majority vote I get it eighty-three
percent right in this particular Network
well that's not a big feat I mean it's
not really that difficult to tell where
someone is black or white but there are
other things that are bit harder to tell
for example voting behavior it turns out
that on average about 70% of your
friends vote the same way as you do so
if I just took a poll of all your
friends and just took a majority vote
amongst your friends
I could probably predict pretty well how
you are going to vote just by knowing
the network's truck
knowing who you're connected to and
knowing how your friends know so here's
some statistics so 70% of your friends
vote about the same way vote the same
way as you do 79 percent of people are
within five years of the age of their
spouse
so people who are marrying other people
of the same age as they are in that high
school example turns out about 67
percent of friends friendships between
people in the same grade in the same
high school study 83 percent of friends
had the same ethnicity a similar result
this is from a study of couples in
California that was done in the 1990s
they found that 72% of people were the
same ethnicity as their partner in the
web example that I showed you the
political web logs 91% of the web links
in that in that web example were between
blogs of the same political persuasion
either too conservative blogs or too
liberal blogs so these look like pretty
impressive results but we have to be a
little bit careful here just giving you
that raw percentage actually doesn't
tell you as much as you might think it
does because if people just sort of
chose their friends totally at random
then there would be some chance that
they would choose people who are the
same as them just by random chance so to
give you an example if you were talking
about the kids in the high school well
there's four grades in the high school
899 10 11 12 and about a quarter of the
kids in each one so if you just chose
your friends totally at random about a
quarter of the time you'd pick people
who were the same grade as you so we
wouldn't be surprised if we saw that 25
percent of friends were in the same
grade we'd say oh well that's just what
we would expect if people chose their
friends at random
so what we do is we say well we expect
25 percent of them to be friends in the
same grade what we observe is that 67
percent of them are in the same grade
and what we calculated is something
called the modularity it's just the
difference of those two numbers so small
bit of math here but very simple we just
take the 67% and
we subtract the 25% that we just we can
already account for because it's obvious
and what we're left with that's the bit
that we're interested in 42 percent
that's 42 percent is a reasonable number
that tells you that there's a real
effect going on here it really is true
that people prefer to be friends with
people in the same grade by a sort of 42
percent overage above what you would
expect if they just chose their friends
from all of the grades so this is the
quantity we call the modularity here's a
couple of other examples of it I told
you that's that 79 percent of people are
within five years of the age of their
spouse but it turns out that if people
just married Pete other people
completely a random sixty-six percent of
them would be within five years of the
age of their spouse why so higher number
well it turns out actually that most
people get married between the ages of
18 and 25 so most people within a very
narrow age range to begin with when they
get married so if they just chose
someone random probably that person is
going to be around the same ageism
anyway so most people even if they just
chose their partners at random would be
within 5 years of the age of their
spouse so now you calculate this
modularity thing 79 percent - 66 percent
you get only 13 percent that's telling
you that actually that result wasn't
particularly significant
there wasn't anything very important
going on there so ignore that one but
this one down here is pretty good
actually this is from the California
study of couples we said that 72% of
them were the same ethnicity as their
partner if they just if it was just
completely random who they chose it
would be 29% so the difference is 43%
which is pretty significant it's telling
you that there really is a significant
preference there for people to have a
partner of the same ethnicity as them
okay
so this gives us a way of measuring this
am awfully effect in networks what I
want to do now is it's gonna seem like I
am gonna change subjects and talk about
a completely different thing but
actually is no completely different it's
actually it'll come right back to this
idea here this idea turns out to be the
base the sort of central idea behind
another very clever idea in network
theory
pose suppose I have a network that looks
like this many networks actually have
this kind of structure they have groups
or communities in in the network meaning
you know there's a clump of people here
that all know each other and there's a
clump of people here that all know each
other but not many people know each
other between the two groups this is a
common thing that we see in a lot of
different networks and I'll actually
show you some examples in a moment so
one of the things that people sometimes
ask about networks is are there
communities in my network and if so can
I find them
turns out this is very useful for
predicting things in networks as I say
I'll show you some examples but so
here's what the trick we want to do we
want to take a network and find the
groups in it but let me think about it
that's kind of similar to what we
already saw with this some awfully thing
where you had for instance two groups in
this high school friendship network we
have a measure this thing called
modularity which allows us to say when
we have a lot of family in our network
so what we're going to do is we're going
to co-opt that idea and apply it to
finding these communities in the network
so the way this is gonna work is suppose
you have some network and you don't know
if there are communities in there but if
there were communities if there was some
division say into two groups and I could
find that division well now let's call
the people in this group type one people
and the people in this group type two
people and then let's measure the hum
awfully of the network let's see how how
strong and effect is it is it really
true that mostly type 1 people want to
be friends with others I want people and
type 2 people want to be friends with
other type 2 people if that were the
case then it would be telling us that we
have groups just like we do down here in
this high school network so we don't
actually need to know what the types of
the people are we just call them 1 & 2
all we need to know is if we knew what
the groups were we could go calculate
the modularity and it would give us a
high number telling us yes we found the
right thing we found the groups in the
network we found two groups where most
of the connections are within the groups
and very
to connections between the groups so the
way this works is you take some network
and you you don't know how you're going
to have to split it up to get the groups
so what you do is you just split it up
in every possible way for each one you
calculate this number the modularity and
then you look through all of them to see
if any of them have a high score and if
they do then that's the way you should
divide up the network that's telling you
that's where the groups are this is
called an optimization method there are
various standard computer techniques for
doing this all you need to know is the
definition of this modularity function
and your network and then your computer
just goes to work looks at every
possible way of dividing up the network
to find one that gets a high score so
let me give you some examples of this in
practice this is a famous network from
the social networks literature it goes
back to the 1970s this is an another
network of students students in a u.s.
university now what this network
represents is it comes from a study of a
karate club in a u.s. university so a
place where students go to practice
their karate was done by a guy called
Wayne Zachary who apparently is an
anthropologist apparently spent about
two years studying the social dynamics
of this particular karate club at this
university and amongst other things
worked out you know who was friends with
whom so he construct friendship networks
like this one here then an interesting
thing happened during the course of his
study a dispute arose within the karate
club it was actually about whether they
should raise the fees doesn't really
matter what it was about but there was
this dispute one faction wanted to raise
the fees another faction didn't want to
raise the fees and eventually the club
just split in two and half of the people
in the club went off and started their
own Club this network that I'm showing
you here is a friendship network taken
from that study this friendship network
crucially was measured before the split
happened so this is the pattern of who
was friends with whom in the original
club before it split up so what we do
now is we take this network and we feed
it into our computer program that does
the community finding care
halation that I just described and what
does it do it says oh yes actually there
are communities in this network meaning
there's one possible way of splitting up
the network that gives us a high
modularity score and that possible way
is the one indicated by this divide in
the picture here this dotted line down
the middle of the picture it turns out
that that division is exactly the same
as the division that happened in real
life when the club split into two parts
so this computer program is in a way
predicting what's going to happen
because remember this network was
measured before the club split up and
from from the patterns of who is friends
with whom before the club split up you
can already see the future of what's
going to happen when it splits the
computer program accurately predicts
from the structure of the network how
it's going to split up when it does
here's another example this is from work
I did I mentioned this yesterday that I
had done some work with marine biologist
David Lu so on social networks of
bottlenose dolphins so dolphins are very
social animals they have well-defined
social networks of which dolphins are
friends with which other ones this is a
network that comes from David's work
with a school of dolphins in doubtful
sound New Zealand
there are 62 dolphins in this network
this is so this is one of the friendship
networks that he constructed for those
dolphins and again during the course of
the study an interesting thing happens
this dolphin here in the middle
represented by the yellow triangle
disappeared we have no idea where it
went it wasn't dead because it came back
about two years later so in the meantime
who knows where it went but the
interesting thing was when that one
dolphin disappeared the whole school of
dolphins split into two separate schools
apparently that one dolphin in the
middle there was just the glue holding
the community together and once he was
gone the thing split apart the two
colors here red and green indicate the
way the school split in real life as
observed by David this dotted line is
you get if you feed the network into our
computer program so in this case you'll
see that it hasn't done it perfectly
correctly right it's got a few dolphins
that are on the wrong side of the line
these these green ones here actually
went with that half of the group and not
with that half the group but it's pretty
close
again it's predicted pretty well how the
the community of dolphins was going to
split into bases just on the observed
social network of which dolphins were
friends with each so this tells you a
couple of different things firstly it
tells you that we can actually predict
things using knowledge of the networks
it also tells you and this is kind of an
important realization that these social
networks really are affecting sort of
the dynamics of people or dolphins or
whatever it is social networks are
having an important impact on the way
people behave because because they're
going with their friends when the thing
splits up in the case of the karate club
for instance people may have had
opinions one way or another about
whether they should raise the fees but
what actually happened when the
network's split is that people stuck
with their friends so whatever people
originally believed about one thing or
another when it's split what was more
important is who are you friends with
and I want to be in the group with my
friends so these friendship networks are
dictating the dynamics of the network
and by knowing what the friendship
networks are we can predict what that
dynamics is going to be in the last
couple of minutes let me just give you
one more example this is a non social
example here is a network constructed by
my friend Valdis Krebs it's a network of
books these are books about US politics
published around the time of the last
but one presidential election so the one
between Bush and Kerry and vulgus has
conveniently color-coded them blue here
on the left and red on the right to
indicate their political persuasion so
for instance over there on the right you
have the faith of george w bush and over
here on the left you have the lies of
george w bush
and and then in the middle there are a
few sort of purple books which looks
like kind of somewhere halfway in
between and then what are the edges what
are the connections between books in
this network well they are frequent Co
purchasing on amazon.com if you buy
books on Amazon you look up a book it
says people who bought this book also
bought these other books how does a Minh
Amazon know that it knows because it has
were purchasing records it's seen many
people buy these these two books
together so what well this did is he
just went and looked up each of these
books is about a hundred of them here
and he looked at which ones you know
were frequently bought with this other
book and put in the connections here so
the connections indicate you know which
pairs of books people are buying
together so now we take this network and
we feed it into our computer program
that detects and groups or communities
within networks and what we find is two
big groups of books one over here which
I've conveniently color-coded blue and
the other one I could be color coded red
and it turns out that they correspond
very nicely to the liberal and
conservative books in this study and so
I could for instance use this to predict
what kind of books people are going to
read if they've read one of the red
books before then it's very likely
they'll read another red book but very
unlikely that they would read a blue
book and similarly if they read a blue
book before it's very likely they will
read another blue book so again this
sort of community structure in the
network can predict things that people
are going to do very good so today what
we've talked about is if I have a
network how can we analyze that network
and tell things about what people are
going to do or what dolphins are going
to do or what the web is going to do I
can guess which people will be most
influential by calculating centrality
measures I can guess who people will be
friends with there'll be people with
friends with people who are in the same
grade as them or something like that
I can guess what books people read I can
guess who they're going to vote for I
can guess who they're going to marry to
some extent there are other things
however that we can do with networks
these are all things that are just using
sort of the static structure the network
all I take into account is sort of what
this is the che
Network you know how many connections do
you have on the network or something
like that however there's a whole other
class of things that we're interested in
to you in networks which is processes
going on on networks the network acts as
a conduit for all sorts of things
spreading through communities news
rumors fashions spread over social
networks of who knows whom diseases
another example they spread over
networks of who's had contacts with whom
once you know what the structure of a
network is perhaps you can predict how
the disease is going to spread if you
can do that maybe you can even work out
some effective way to vaccinate a
community to prevent the disease from
spreading all these are ideas to do with
the spread of things on networks and
these are the topics that I will talk
about tomorrow in the last of these
three lectures however for the moment
I'm out of time
so I'll shut up now thank you all very
much for your attention I'd be happy to
answer questions
any questions yes
okay so that's an excellent question so
I don't know the answer to that question
that's not something you can tell
directly from the network the network
allows you to see these effects and
quantify these effects give actual
measurements of them it doesn't tell you
what the reasons are for these effects
going on in the first place however what
a lot of people are interested in doing
is and I mentioned this briefly
yesterday is often when you do these
studies of networks you measure a lot of
other things in addition to measuring
the network so you ask people who are
you friends with but then you ask people
a lot of other things so for instance
that's the ad Health Study of the u.s.
high school kids asked a lot of
questions about you know what after
school activities the kids indulged in
and you know they would ask you know
what are the age of your friends and
what things do your friends do and you
know so say well they're trying to get
at the reasons why people were friends
so in principle there is data there that
you could look at so you could look at
some non Hamas friendship you know
friendship between two kids in different
grades or whatever and you could ask
what other things between them could
have been responsible for this so yeah I
mean usually friendships do form because
people have things in common but it's
certainly possible for them to have some
things in common and some other things
not in common so what you may be seeing
is the things they have not in common
and then some other thing there that
they have in common that's the reason
for the friendship so in principle those
data are there and there so people sort
of realize that there's this issue and
are measuring those things but in this
particular case I can't actually tell
you what the answer is that's not
something that comes from the network
itself yes question back there
oh so excellent questions so yes so well
so first it wasn't first of all it
wasn't me it was David Liu so who did
the actual studies of the dolphins but
so the the lone dolphin did come back
and indeed when it came back the two
groups fused together into a single
group as well by then the network wasn't
exactly the same as it was before this
fishin where they divided and that's in
part because some other dolphins had
been born and some dolphins had died in
the mean time but the the actual the
fuse network afterwards that was
actually quite remarkably similar to the
one there's been beforehand so it really
seems like this the the yellow triangle
in the center of the picture there was
somehow sort of the fulcrum holding
these two groups together when it went
away they split up when it came back
they came back together again so so yeah
it seems like it was really quite a
repeatable experiment in that sense as a
question of we yeah so fair question
it's predictive in the sense that the
data on the network were measured before
the split happened so if somebody had
said I think this is going to split how
is it going to split then we could have
fed this into our computer program and
made a pretty good guess about how it
was going to split however two caveats
first of all nobody did ask us that we
can't predict that it's going to split
all we could do is predict how it was
going to split and second of all of
course I'm showing you this example
because it works if it hadn't works I
probably wouldn't have shown you this
one so we should be a little bit careful
about that but a good question yes
question Mike there
well so that's also a good question so
Amazon does not share with us the
details of how it does those
calculations so you know for obvious
reasons that's some proprietary thing so
we don't know how accurate those you
know people who bought this book also
bought these other books are but I mean
the the assumption is that it's based on
co purchasing data and hence they're not
actually making a guess about whether
this is a conservative book or a liberal
book they're just looking at what books
are bought together and and I find it
very reasonable to suppose that you can
you can do that the books of the same
political situation are commonly bought
together and therefore you don't
actually need to cheat and know about
what political persuasion the books are
represent represent in order to do this
accurately and indeed you know given
that Amazon sells millions of books on
its website it really wouldn't be very
practical for it to try and make value
judgments about the content of books and
then link them together by hands because
it would just be an enormous amount of
work it's certainly in Amazon's interest
to develop these clever algorithms that
use the network structure and work out
which books are connected together in
some automated way so the computers can
do all the work and you don't need to do
these kinds of things by hand so it's a
fair question we don't actually know how
that worked so there's no we don't know
for certain that there wasn't some hand
tuning going on there but I think it's
probably the case that it was just
frequent Co purchasing that went into
that yeah
Oh a good question so they actually do
know the genealogy of most of dolphins
not by genetics but just by by either
watching mothers give birth to dolphins
or by behave mostly by behavior
afterwards apparently there's quite an
extended period when the offspring hang
out with their mother and so there are
groups within the social network that
correspond to who's descended from whom
and it actually turns out so we did some
of this in the paper that we wrote about
this that you can also ask not just
about the two big groups that the
community splits into but also there are
smaller splits within those groups and
it turns out that those are mostly upon
matrilineal lines meaning that the
offspring of a particular mother tend to
be friends later on in life so so there
so they do know those kinds of things
and there's evidence that that does
affect the shape of the social network
later on in life yeah question right in
the back there I don't know for certain
where's Kevin Bacon the maybe the so the
apocryphal tale is that this game was
invented by two college kids from
somewhere or other and their claim was
that Kevin Bacon was the center of the
movie universe and the way they were
going to prove it is look you can get
from any other actor to Kevin Bacon in
just a small number of steps and of
course of course this is a completely
ridiculous assertion because you can
take any other actor and do exactly the
same trick with it and it'll work just
fine
and moreover Kevin Bacon is not even the
most central actor in the network in
this sense as you saw actually it should
really be the six degrees of Christopher
Lee because he's the one who's really
the center of a central network so yeah
why they chose Kevin Bacon I I really
don't know yeah maybe it was maybe was
just for that reason
a good question so in some cases yes
I mean in in some cases you know to
think whatever we do with people's
social network they're not going to care
about but there are other cases where
knowing things about what's going on on
the network do change the structure of
the network there's some feedback there
so one of the things that you notice for
instance is so I talked about this
homophily affect the people tend to like
to be friends with other people who are
similar to them but it's also true that
people tend to form opinions that are
similar to those of the people they're
friends with so there's a bit of a
chicken and egg problem here how do you
know which came first so if you're
talking for instance about voting
behavior it's certainly true that most
people vote like their friends but is
that because they became friends with
people who are like-minded or is it
because they adopted opinions from their
friends probably in fact both of those
things are happening people change their
opinions to match their friends and
people change their friends to match
their opinions so both of those things
are affecting each other and the
structure of the network itself is
certainly being affected by said what's
going on on the network there's another
question in the far corner there so I
think well so first of all I'm not a big
expert on your own network so I should
be careful what I say but my my main
feeling is that these kind of
statistical techniques are probably not
going to tell us very much about neural
networks and the reason is that the
things we're interested in neural
networks are how sort of particular
circuits in the network achieve the
things that they do so we're really
interested in the details of the network
whereas with a lot of these networks
that have been telling you here it's
more a sort of big homogeneous thing you
know every node represents a person of
course people are different but in some
sense it's sort of all the same and then
these kind of statistical techniques
turn out to give reasonable results
there are certainly people who try and
do these things with neural networks and
it's certainly I think it's probably
possible that there are some structural
results you could get out like that but
I think the really big question is about
neural net
you know like how do we think have to be
solved by some other techniques so I'm a
little bit cautious about how far you
can take these techniques in the case of
neural networks okay maybe the question
over here huh
well so no I I don't know of that but
certainly there are people who are
interested in analyzing political
networks and I mentioned a bit about
this in the question and answer session
at the end of last night's lecture so
certainly people have have studied
political networks you know things like
which politicians sit on committees with
which others and which co-sponsored
bills which others and things like that
and you can use this for instance to do
things like predicts how people will
vote on certain measures or to rate
politicians according to some sort of
political spectrum how far are they to
one side or another side so there are
definitely people who are interested in
political networks of one kind or
another and are doing interesting things
with them however I don't actually know
any specific examples of things you say
of a political organization using this
for something so thank you
you